un poco tiempo después de conocerse la
renuncia del presidente ibrahim muaqqat
keita se revela el rostro de quienes
tomaron el poder un oficial de la fuerza
armada se declaró jefe de la junta
militar que liderará el país
[Música]
mi nombre es el coronel así migoya
presidente del comité nacional para la
salvación del pueblo era mi deber
reunirme con los distintos secretarios
generales para que juntos pudiéramos
asegurarles nuestro apoyo a la
continuidad del estado no podemos
permitirnos más errores al realizar la
intervención de ayer ante ponemos a
nuestro país
periodistas locales dijeron a france 24
que koica era el jefe de las fuerzas
especiales de malí este se encuentra
acompañado por israel para que malik
díaz radio cámara y chica fanta mady
dembélé militares con altos rangos
dentro del ejército y entrenamiento en
el extranjero específicamente en rusia y
francia los rebeldes han manifestado su
compromiso para celebrar elecciones en
el país además invitan a la población a
retomar la vida normal
el comité invita a la población a
realizar libremente sus actividades y
pide que reanuden labores
el comité invita a los funcionarios
públicos a volver a trabajar a partir
del 20 de agosto se le asegura a la
población que se han tomado todas las
medidas para proteger al personal sus
pertenencias y su lugar de trabajo
por ahora no existe claridad sobre cuál
fue el rol que cada uno de los
participantes tuvo en el golpe de estado
pero éste se dio en medio de crecientes
tensiones entre el ejército y el
gobierno debido a que los militares
responsabilizan a este último entre
otras cosas el aumento en los ataques
yihadistas contra los uniformados en la
región del sahel